hi it's me I'm not dead which is an
awful surprise considering how many
people wrote my obituary yesterday
preemptively in case I did die but I
didn't so suck on that I'm an old man
that's not what I meant to say I meant
to say I'm a mature adult but some how
old man came out but I am a mature adult
that has been sanctioned nope that's the
wrong word I am a mature adult that has
been given the responsibility of this
human form in front of you I couldn't
have said this any weirder believe it or
not I actually do know how to take care
of myself except for that one time when
I stopped my hair with butter yeah I
jumped off the monkey bars broke my arm
and I jumped off the stairs and then I
broke my head open almost died then
but honestly thank you guys so much for
all the love and outpouring from the
community that I've seen thus far even
though it's sometimes it did seem like
screaming and cursing I knew there was
love deep down in those messages of hate
but honestly I'm not a hundred percent
better yet so I'm gonna go to a game
that you guys have requested again
because there is this sandbox mode in
totally accurate battle simulator that
allows you to hypothetically make any
battle of your dreams so I'm gonna do
just that I'm gonna go through a whole
bunch I move
[Music]
Celie professional youtuber with 14
million subscribers I definitely deserve
I'm not lying again I am good I am great
so anyway sandbox go to town you
who is the better why can I not
move forward that's good well is it woo
it is - is our - better than one
come get some well got to him boink
boink and ate a dick oh I think that
might have been a little convulse elated
we're gonna get you this time they're
not gonna gang up on you all at once
they're gonna line up so you can beat
the snot out of them so we've determined
that three peasants is better than one
boxer oh no you guys are gonna get poked
I bet you're gonna die well that's one
down to the range does nothing when they
hump you from either side Oh No get them
well now man those toothpicks are gonna
do some damage someday
well they're gonna hug it out
they're peaceful Bunch
well okay so we got a hundred and twenty
peasants versus one Rocky Balboa let's
see what happens
Oh God well my computer can handle it
for some reason I don't know how I think
you're gonna you didn't even get to one
that that boxer also now has Apollo
Creed next to it so as rocky and Apollo
Creed versus everyone that didn't like
the didn't like Rocky 5
dang they clobbered them I feel like one
chariot would do pretty good I'm gonna
have them coming from way downtown I
think one cherry it's gonna have a good
time with this bunch go get him go get
him Sally sac well you missed some okay
all right
oh he was right we're gonna blast him
with ballista from downtown
well they'll fire eventually don't worry
they're not actually gonna hurt him
there's a wolf those guys in front sure
caught a mouthful holy are you okay
nice hair I think 100 peasants are
unstoppable oh geez
what are you doing where's your eyes
it's just a soulless monster Wow okay
what are you doing all right easy is he
dead is he dead is he is he dead I can't
I can't quite tell oh my god oh my
they're just humping that dead one oh
yeah
oh good lord this is inappropriate that
is that is straight-up humping that is
100% hump they're dying of exhaustion
from the orgy
my god leave that poor guy alone stuff
in his head back and forth he's dead I
don't think this video is gonna get
monetized you like this dramatic music
playing as we watch this guy BAP his
dick around back and forth
oh so sensually oh be bad now oh no
Last Man Standing you're doing it man
you're doing a great job
you you back whatever that is yeah
whatever okay so that didn't work at all
we got a lot of watches and I believe
that of the right length to kill all
them watch it
wash aah
ooh
almost but not quite we got some bat Wow
but what what I didn't even look there
were guys on that before there were not
that's not what in the world are you
doing
why are you oh why are you shaking
why were you shaking I don't know why
you were shaking I'm rocky this is my
rocky bridge uh-oh
well get some wash it up Oh our
crotch rockets are better than your
crotch rockets man so good that we have
qualified flexible people for this
endeavor Wow you guys didn't do
stopped working oh this guy this guy's
going the distance on the twerk here the
other guys are falling to pieces all
around him he's gonna work a nightmare
out of here oh geez
what are you Wow I uh I got some
questions about this right here
what why why is this a thing what why
why do you guys need why why I know that
was intense but why this is strategic
this is a Napoleon z-- method for doing
something don't worry don't ask it I
knew whoa wait what yeah I'm gonna take
a look in there
some don't seem right things keep flying
out at high speed but apparently this is
okay Wow all right there buddy
hello horsies nice button there ooh boy
although I don't know who's winning oh
geez
why is it why is that good why why are
you sir sir if you're trying to pretend
to be dead you're not doing a very good
job at it okay my computer didn't why
are you over here sir
you're not doing your job sir see how
everyone else doing their job about to
fire their cannons that did don't come
any closer don't come any closer
Oh God you might be in trouble well
you got some no you turned your backs
they're still coming for you
I see the beady eyes on them ooh that
guy got clobbered Oh Oh God
oh geez I thought that guy was gonna get
blasted girl get blasted your get
blasted
Oh yep you almost had him spank that
rump well it looks like blue one wobbu
ski ooh now this is of the womb good god
holy Oh
oh my god good go I don't know what's
happening there I don't know what
anything is going on here are we still
fighting there's two people alive and
holy I forgot the catapult fire so
fast we're going farmer V if you hold it
with the pointy end forward you might
have a little more success there buddy
uh-oh someone's gonna get stabbed up
good well I don't look good huh it seems
whoa it seems to me that the bodies are
actually getting pinned into each other
but the farmers seem to have an edge on
it so spearmen are useless why would
anybody have spearmen they don't make
any goddamn sense do you what you're
doing over there all right go for it
you can't penetrate these defense out oh
they penetrated so hard
I forgot that shield Minh actually can't
attack so I was hoping that this stupid
idea the other team would bleed through
their strategy and they'd just end up
killing themselves Oh got a few
stragglers left my god I can't believe
that worked
alright so that's about all the options
that I could possibly explore in this
game I really don't know what else I can
do until the full game is released but
either way thank you guys again for all
the love and outpouring from the
community that has wished me better help
than what I've got and I am feeling
better and it will be back on a normal
schedule very soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]
you your own teammate that's what
happened this
[Music]